Like I could I can dream and see on fire assembly. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 192 recorded on July 11 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce we chat with Kevlin Henney in part three of our five-part series about systems programming and more. Here's a fundamental question. Sorry, the dog was throwing up this morning, which is why I was tasked with keeping her in my eyesight. Ah, right. I was just assuming, given that we're all on on teams here for those of you listening in podcast land and um and so therefore i always thought it was compulsory when you are you know you're on teams you're on
就像我可以做梦，看到火灾现场。欢迎收听ADSP播客第192期，录制于2024年7月11日。我是Connor，今天和我的联合主持人Bryce一起，我们邀请了Kevlin Henney，这是我们关于系统编程及更多内容的五部分系列节目的第三部分。这是一个根本性的问题。抱歉，狗狗今天早上呕吐了，所以我被指派盯着她。啊，对了。我只是假设，鉴于我们都在Teams上，对于那些在播客中收听的朋友们，嗯，所以我一直认为当你身处Teams时，这是强制性的，你在
zoom or whatever there has to be an animal and i just thought yes i thought that bryce was was okay it's my turn i you know here is here is the uh the meeting dog. Usually I would do that for a few minutes. But in this particular case, if I see the thing is she's so quiet. If I didn't sit here on the bed with her, she would wander off and potentially throw up again. And then I wouldn't know about it. And then I would get in trouble with mom. So you got to stay here with me. I know you would like to go elsewhere, but sorry. Anyways, the fundamental question.
Zoom或其他什么软件上，必须有一只动物，我刚才就想，是的，我以为Bryce没问题，轮到我了，你知道，这就是所谓的“会议犬”。通常我会那样做几分钟。但在这种特殊情况下，你看，她太安静了。如果我不坐在这张床上陪着她，她就会走开，可能会再次呕吐。然后我就不会知道了。那样我就会被妈妈责备。所以你得留在这里陪我。我知道你想去别的地方，但抱歉。总之，根本性的问题。
Fundamental question. Does software get better with time? Or sorry, do we get better at software over time? Are things better now than they were and will they continue to get better? I think that's actually more than one question, question interestingly although you're offering different perspectives on it i think um i think collectively we as individuals and as developers and development organizations i think we do get better i think there are a number of things that are taken for granted now and things that people just do that they never realized were a struggle that they never realized they that you know was a thing to worry about in fact i in digging around i did a did a talk at um the acu conference um in april um
根本性问题。软件会随着时间推移而变得更好吗？或者抱歉，我们对软件的掌握会随着时间推移而变得更好吗？现在的情况比过去更好吗？未来会继续变好吗？有趣的是，我认为这实际上不止一个问题，尽管你们对此提出了不同的看法，但我认为，嗯，我认为作为一个整体，作为个人、开发者和开发组织，我认为我们确实在进步。我认为现在有很多事情被认为是理所当然的，人们只是在做这些事，却从未意识到这曾经是一种挣扎，从未意识到这曾经是需要担心的事情。事实上，我在四处挖掘时，曾在四月份的ACU会议上做过一次演讲，嗯
basically uh on data abstraction i wanted to kind of focus on the history of that but also to bring it up today. One of the things I looked at was Barbara Liskoff's, I've been a fan of Barbara Liskoff's work for many years in terms of language design, the Clue language and her original work on data abstraction. But I'm nerdy like that. So I already knew this stuff, but I saw a couple of her talks and she said,
基本上是关于数据抽象的，我想重点谈谈它的历史，但也想把它带到今天。我研究的事情之一是Barbara Liskov的工作，多年来我一直是Barbara Liskov工作的粉丝，特别是在语言设计、Clue语言以及她关于数据抽象的原创工作方面。但我就是这么书呆子气。所以我已经知道这些东西了，但我看了她的一些演讲，她说，
yeah, when she was given the Turing Award, I think 2008, one of the um one of the things that uh one of the critics online said is why is she getting an award for this everybody knows this stuff and they know it because she did this you know prior to 1973 1974 data abstraction was not a thing um and pretty much everybody that, you know, although there was an idea of object orientation around, her work on abstract data types had the greatest influence, particularly on statically typed languages and the stuff that Bjarne later did
是的，当她获得图灵奖时，我想是2008年，嗯，网上的一位评论家说，为什么她因为这个获得奖项？每个人都知道这些东西。他们知道是因为她做了这些。你知道，在1973年、1974年之前，数据抽象还不存在。而且几乎每个人，你知道，尽管当时有面向对象的概念，但她关于抽象数据类型的工作影响最大，特别是在静态类型语言和Bjarne后来所做的事情上
and some of the evolution of it. And everybody just regards it as like, yeah, yeah, of course. It's always been like this. It's like, no, it hasn't. Somebody had to do this and had to do this. And so people are able to build on a lot of features in languages, in libraries, in ecosystems, but also in the way we disseminate knowledge. I think, you know, we can kind of, okay, slightly egotistical from the point of view of the developer view. So collective egotism is a thing.
以及它的一些演变。每个人都认为这就像是，“是啊，是啊，当然了。一直都是这样的。”就像是，“不，并不是。”有人必须做这件事，而且必须这样做。所以人们能够在语言、库、生态系统中构建很多功能，也能在传播知识的方式上构建。我认为，你知道，我们可以，好吧，从开发者的角度来看，这稍微有点自负。所以集体自负是存在的。
A lot of things have happened as a result of developers wanting to communicate. The internet, email. I mean, literally, it is developers trying to talk to other developers. How do we communicate? Usenet, and therefore, ultimately, all forms of sharing of data. Open source, the idea, oh, guess what? I've got a piece of code. I wonder if there's a standard way we could share that and others take advantage of it. How can we share our knowledge? Well, tell you what, let's put this on a place that we can all get to. It was FTP servers, and then it was World Wide Web. And then it was just like, it's just that we're very good at solving some of these problems. Our ability to disseminate knowledge is actually really good. So I think in the 2020s, we are definitely building on a lot of benefits that somebody from former eras would go like, wow, you know, you guys have really got it together.
很多事情的发生都是因为开发者想要交流。互联网、电子邮件。我的意思是，从字面上看，这就是开发者试图与其他开发者交谈。我们如何沟通？Usenet，因此，最终，所有形式的数据共享。开源，这个想法，哦，你猜怎么着？我有一段代码。我想知道是否有一种标准的方法可以分享它，让其他人也能受益。我们如何分享我们的知识？好吧，告诉你，让我们把它放在一个我们都能访问的地方。那是FTP服务器，然后是万维网。然后就像是，只是因为我们非常擅长解决其中一些问题。我们传播知识的能力实际上非常好。所以我认为在2020年代，我们绝对是在利用很多前几个时代的人会说“哇，你们真的做到了”的优势。
But when they look closely, they might be also disappointed by, yeah, you're a bit better, but not as much better as we thought you could, given all of this. So I think that's the thing. I think that we have a benefit, but also we are not in a position where we're making the best of it. And then what's the statistic? I don't know. It varies. But half of all developers have been developing for less than a year. It's something like that, you know. So the influx of people is huge. And then trying to communicate this, if we were slightly older and stuffier, and that was the whole of the demographic, then actually we might have a different story. But the point is that we've got a lot of people who are coming into development, and they don't have the backstory. They don't have the history. They don't see all of this or understand why such a thing is a big deal and and so therefore they are not in a position they're learning for the first time and so
但当他们仔细观察时，他们可能也会感到失望，因为“是的，你们好一点了，但并没有我们想象的那么好，考虑到所有这些。”所以我认为这就是问题所在。我认为我们有优势，但我们并没有处于充分利用它的位置。那么统计数据是多少？我不知道。它会有所不同。但一半的开发者开发时间不到一年。大概就是这样，你知道。所以涌入的人数是巨大的。然后试图沟通这一点，如果我们稍微年长一点、古板一点，而那又是全部的人口统计，那么实际上我们可能会有不同的故事。但重点是，我们有很多进入开发领域的人，他们没有背景故事。他们没有历史。他们看不到所有这些，也不理解为什么这样的事情是大问题，因此他们没有处于那种位置，他们是第一次学习，所以
therefore most developers are on a on on the earlier part of their learning curve and i think that's the that might characterize our profession, perhaps in a different way to many other professions where there's much more of a steady state. I think we're operating much more in a power law. So that's what may prevent us from taking full advantage of all the benefits that we actually have created. But there are also all of that, all of this progress,
因此，大多数开发者都处于学习曲线的早期阶段，我认为这可能使我们的职业具有某种特征，也许与许多其他职业不同，那些职业有更多的稳定状态。我认为我们更多是在幂律下运作。所以这可能就是阻止我们充分利用我们实际上已经创造的所有好处的原因。但也有所有这些，所有这些进步，
all this greater interconnectedness it comes with downsides too um like like take one like security like in this new bold world where we have all this open source code and everything's connected like one like when everything's on the internet just like the internet itself like opened up like these attack surfaces to like almost all digital technology and and things like uh things like uh hey baby it's okay somebody's at the door presumably um things like open source and package managers have opened up supply chain attacks. That's like a whole new thing that we have to think about that we didn't have to deal with before. Yeah. And I think that's an important, that is an important thing because yeah. I'm going to have to, this may be my fridge,
所有这些更大的互联性也带来了负面影响。嗯，比如拿安全来说，在这个我们拥有所有这些开源代码且一切都相互连接的新大胆世界里，就像当一切都在互联网上时，就像互联网本身一样，向几乎所有的数字技术开放了这些攻击面，还有像，嘿宝贝，没关系，有人在门口，大概是，还有像开源和包管理器这样的东西开启了供应链攻击。这就像是一个我们需要考虑的全新事物，我们以前不必处理。是的。我认为这是一个重要的，这是一个重要的事情，因为是的。我得，这可能是我的冰箱，
which they were supposed to deliver a new fridge yesterday. And there's a whole story about why we have to get another new fridge because the fridge that we had was a new fridge, but I'll be right back. Talk amongst yourselves. So I'm going to pick up the point that Bryce made there. That whole, I think that, and we've seen it on the people front as well. You know, it's not, there's a social implication here as well. When you start increasing connection, there's a whole lot of benefits. There's a lot of really good network effects, but it's also an amplifier for other things and it creates new possibilities. And security is one of them. And the language or the focus on security in modern development has shifted hugely, even in
他们本应昨天送来一台新冰箱。关于为什么我们必须再买一台新冰箱有一个完整的故事，因为我们之前的那台冰箱是一台新冰箱，但我马上回来。你们自己聊聊。所以我要接着Bryce刚才提到的那一点说。关于人员方面，我们也看到了这一点。你知道，这里也有社会影响。当你开始增加连接时，有很多好处。有很多非常好的网络效应，但它也是其他事物的放大器，并创造了新的可能性。安全就是其中之一。现代开发中对安全的语言或关注点发生了巨大的转变，即使在
just the last five years. And that's not going to change, but that comes as a consequence of connecting everything together. But the assumptions that we have is really interesting. So yeah, do you remember I mentioned I worked in the electricity industry? And that was in the 1990s. And one of the things that we were working on, SCADA systems, so supervisory control and data acquisition systems that sit in substations, they monitor stuff. Every electricity network has these things. OK, so you've got all of that. And we were developing one of these. And we were literally communicating between substations and kind of headquarters
仅仅过去五年里。而且这种情况不会改变，但这正是将所有东西连接在一起的结果。但我们所持有的假设真的很有趣。所以，是的，你还记得我提到过我在电力行业工作吗？那是在20世纪90年代。我们正在研究的事情之一是SCADA系统，即位于变电站的监控和数据采集系统，它们监控各种东西。每个电力网络都有这些东西。好的，所以你拥有所有这些。我们正在开发其中之一。我们实际上是在变电站和总部之间进行通信
using wet pieces of string. It was kind of like modem die-up speed. Wet pieces of string. Wet pieces of string. Modem die-up speed, okay? So therefore, for us, having a compact representation for our wire-level protocols was really important because you don't have you know we we worried
使用湿绳子。这有点像调制解调器的拨号速度。湿绳子。湿绳子。调制解调器拨号速度，好吗？所以对我们来说，为我们的线路级协议提供紧凑的表示非常重要，因为你没有，你知道，我们担心
about bandwidth in a way that um people now simply wouldn't understand um right and so we worried about that that was our one of our main things it's like okay it's got to be really compact and then the question of security came up and it's just like i remember pretty much the decision was well we probably don't need to worry much about security because nobody would be stupid enough to put their um uh their you know their fundamental infrastructure uh onto the internet where it could be attacked um we're already aware of worms and and other issues and it's just like yeah but you wouldn't put the electricity grid online would you no not not so. You'd make sure that was it. Yeah. Now, that's charming from the modern perspective. But also,
带宽的方式，嗯，现在的人根本无法理解，对吧？所以我们担心那个，那是我们的主要事情之一，就像是，好的，它必须非常紧凑。然后安全问题出现了，我记得几乎当时的决定是，好吧，我们可能不需要太担心安全，因为没有人会蠢到把他们的，嗯，你知道，他们的基础基础设施放到互联网上，在那里它可能会受到攻击。我们已经意识到蠕虫和其他问题，就像是，是的，但你不会把电网联网，对吧？不，不会。你会确保那是。是的。现在，从现代的角度来看，这很迷人。但同时，
it does betray the assumptions that we had because our driver was, well, the minute we start using any security, then that's going to involve encryption. That's potentially, or that's extra stuff. If we were to use secure sockets, then actually we lose a whole load of bandwidth by doing that. So, having made everything really, really compact, we'd immediately lose that and there's a whole load of issues that we'd have with that that were performance related. Now, we took those decisions consciously. And hindsight suggests, you know what? It turns out people do put this stuff on. The Stuxnet worm was an example of the fact, yeah, you can disable another country's nuclear power stations via the internet. Oops. Consequences of connectivity, that connectivity went even further than people anticipated and
它确实暴露了我们所持有的假设，因为我们的驱动力是，好吧，一旦我们开始使用任何安全措施，那就会涉及加密。这可能是，或者那是额外的东西。如果我们使用安全套接字，那么实际上我们通过这样做会损失大量的带宽。所以，在把所有东西都做得非常非常紧凑之后，我们会立即失去它，而且我们会有很多与性能相关的问题。现在，我们是有意识地做出了这些决定。事后看来，你知道吗？事实证明人们确实把这些东西放上去了。Stuxnet蠕虫就是一个例子，是的，你可以通过互联网禁用另一个国家的核电站。哎呀。连接性的后果，那种连接性比人们预期的走得更远，而且
that you know there are all of these issues but it does mean everybody now has to worry about security in a way that they were only paying lip service to even only you know five or ten years ago um it's one of those things is like everybody's concerned your language has to be safe you're you're you're top to top to bottom whole stack, we have to know what's going on. Because the fact is that most of your software build is not yours. It comes from other places. Who knows what's there? And we're seeing that that has changed the landscape of what people are wary of. But it's also changed the way they build. And yeah, you're going to get one with the other. But I think that is an important consequence. And we're going to get one with the other. But I think that is an important consequence.
你知道，所有这些问题都存在，但这确实意味着每个人现在都必须以一种他们甚至在五到十年前只是敷衍了事的方式来担心安全。嗯，这是其中之一，就像每个人都很关心，你的语言必须是安全的，你从上到下整个堆栈，我们必须知道发生了什么。因为事实是，你的大部分软件构建不是你自己的。它来自其他地方。谁知道那里有什么？我们看到这改变了人们所警惕的领域。但这也改变了他们的构建方式。是的，你会得到一个伴随另一个。但我认为这是一个重要的后果。我们会得到一个伴随另一个。但我认为这是一个重要的后果。
And we're going to see that for pretty much any language. Again, if I enter the language space today with a new language, you can bet, you know, 20 years ago, nobody would have said, so tell me about security and memory safety of your language. It's not likely that would have been a big issue. But now that's going to be one of the first five questions they're going to ask. Hey, you've got a new programming language. Tell me about this.
我们将看到几乎任何语言都是如此。同样，如果我今天带着一种新语言进入语言领域，你可以打赌，你知道，20年前，没有人会说，那么告诉我关于你的语言的安全性和内存安全性。这不太可能是一个大问题。但现在这将是他们要问的前五个问题之一。嘿，你有一种新的编程语言。告诉我这个。
How do you do that? So the priorities have shifted, which is obviously some languages in a better position to take advantage of that or to be able to say, yep, already sorted. Other languages, oh, we have to do a bit of catching up. But that has now become such a concern that if you were creating a new language that you wanted people to take seriously, you have to answer that question almost by the time you've read the first half of the landing page for that language. You've got to have answered that question. Well, it's interesting. Yeah, yeah, it's exactly the priorities and also the constraints have shifted. You know, if you think about it, in the 70s, the power company had had the money, they may not have been able to get the sort of connection between substations that the programmers would have wanted. Because the technology may not have existed for that.
你是怎么做到的？所以优先级已经转移了，这显然使一些语言处于更好的位置来利用这一点，或者能够说，是的，已经解决了。其他语言，哦，我们必须做一点追赶。但这现在已经成为一个如此令人担忧的问题，如果你正在创造一种你想让人们认真对待的新语言，你几乎必须在读完该语言落地页的前半部分时就回答这个问题。你必须已经回答了这个问题。嗯，这很有趣。是的，是的，这正是优先级，而且约束条件也发生了变化。你知道，如果你想想看，在70年代，电力公司有钱，他们可能无法获得程序员想要的变电站之间的那种连接。因为那种技术可能根本不存在。
Whereas, so we used to, computing started off in this era that was very heavily resource constrained. Today, we are much more cost constrained. And that cost can be either on the actual dollar cost for compute. Like, okay, we have an unlimited amount of compute. We can get as much from AWS as we'd want, but it'll cost you. And the cost can also be on the power side. Like, okay, you could do a whole lot of compute, but if you do a whole lot of compute,
然而，计算开始于一个资源非常受限的时代。今天，我们更多的是受成本限制。这种成本可以是计算的实际美元成本。比如，好的，我们有无限的计算量。我们可以从AWS获得我们想要的尽可能多的计算量，但这会花钱。成本也可以是在电力方面。比如，好的，你可以做大量的计算，但如果你做大量的计算，
you're going to drain the power on your phone real fast. And so it are like, it's much more of an efficiency, more than resource constraint limits us. And then also, we have this, you know, safety, security and reliability concern, that is much more of a a priority than it than it used to be. And I mean, maybe it's that like all of the things that we deal with today, like the cost and the, you know, energy concerns and safety, maybe those would have been more of a priority back in the day, but they just weren't because, you know, there were bigger problems like, you know, oh, we only,
你会很快耗尽手机的电量。所以这就像，它更多的是一种效率，而不是资源限制限制了我们。而且，我们还有这个，你知道，安全、保障和可靠性的担忧，这比过去更加优先。我的意思是，也许是因为我们今天处理的所有事情，比如成本和，你知道，能源担忧和安全，也许这些在过去会是更优先考虑的事情，但它们只是没有，因为，你知道，有更大的问题，比如，你知道，哦，我们只有，
we only have this much memory, you know, we only, we only have this much memory. We only have this much bandwidth. So, yeah, I think that kind of speaks to something else. We're always going to hit some kind of constraint. And I would also argue that power is itself a resource. If anything, it's the original resource. And I love the fact that the mobile phone, I've got a Samsung. It's got better battery life than my previous Samsung.
我们只有这么多内存，你知道，我们只有，我们只有这么多内存。我们只有这么多带宽。所以，是的，我认为这说明了其他一些事情。我们总是会遇到某种限制。我还会争辩说，电力本身就是一种资源。如果说有什么的话，它是最初的资源。我喜欢手机这一点，我有一个三星。它的电池寿命比我以前的三星要好。
And we're now actually almost still not quite at the levels that my Nokia in the mid-90s had. In other words, you know, in the sense of being able to, how long can I go without recharging? You know, we hit different boundaries at different times um and as you said memory was an issue in fact there's been some really interesting cases where we've ended up with this curious mismatch and we saw it um with um the pc at one point suddenly you've got all this memory but it's not addressable because it's a 16-bit system and you have to do weird things and then we kind of got over that and then we hit in the 2000s we hit the issue of like well yeah i've got loads of memory but i've only got 32-bit addressable um and uh and then it's a case of like well maybe actually it's cheaper to run things across multiple machines um so you've got the kind of the hadoop kind of approach of like yeah let's
我们现在实际上几乎还没有达到我在90年代中期拥有的诺基亚的水平。换句话说，你知道，在能够，我可以在不充电的情况下使用多久？你知道，我们在不同的时间遇到了不同的边界，嗯，正如你所说，内存是一个问题，事实上，有一些非常有趣的情况，我们最终遇到了这种奇怪的不匹配，我们看到了它，嗯，随着，嗯，个人电脑在某一点上突然你有了所有这些内存，但它不可寻址，因为它是16位系统，你必须做一些奇怪的事情，然后我们克服了这一点，然后在2000年代我们遇到了这样的问题，嗯，是的，我有大量的内存，但我只有32位可寻址，嗯，而且，这是一个问题，嗯，也许实际上在多台机器上运行东西更便宜；所以你有了Hadoop那种方法，就像，是的，让我们
just break this break this computation up scatter it across the network um and then it's a case of people saying, well, actually, it's always faster if you can put it on the same machine. We've got 64-bit addressing. So I've worked with one team. Their limit, they'd hit the 32-bit limit, even though their machine had clearly a lot more than 4 gigabytes. and so therefore we had to solve the problem with various optimizations of compacting you know really you know messing up the c++ data structure to kind of like oh we're going to save a bit here and a bit there so that when we multiply it up to large data so not big data but large data it will still fit in memory but also the other option of one of the other systems they used was like we have to run it across separate processes because that's the only other way we can take advantage of that you
只是把这个计算分解，散布到网络上，然后人们说，嗯，实际上，如果你能把它放在同一台机器上，它总是更快。我们有64位寻址。所以我曾与一个团队合作。他们的限制，他们达到了32位限制，即使他们的机器显然有远多于4GB的内存。因此，我们必须通过各种优化来解决这个问题，压缩，你知道，真的，你知道，弄乱C++数据结构，以至于，哦，我们要在这里节省一点，在那里节省一点，这样当我们把它乘以大数据时，不是大数据，而是大量数据，它仍然能装进内存，但另一个选择是他们使用的其他系统之一，就像我们必须在单独的进程中运行它，因为那是我们能利用它的唯一其他方式，你
hit 64 bits suddenly you can address it but now we also start hitting the other limits each time we do something you hit the other limits and go back to connectivity um we hit light speed um as an issue you know it's that it's one of those things that you's 20 milliseconds between London and New York. So if you've got a trading system and somebody says, oh, we need to have New York and London in sync with respect to 10 milliseconds, you need a Nobel Prize because you are not going to break that limit. This is one of those laws you don't get an option on. You can't open up a config file and say, you know, I'm just going to change the speed of light today i think it should be faster well let's reboot the system with a faster speed of light so we found and this the light limit is genuine in the sense of um the systems we're working with it's um not i'm not just talking space travel and stuff like
达到64位，突然你可以寻址它，但现在我们也开始遇到其他限制，每次我们做某事，你都会遇到其他限制，回到连接性，我们遇到了光速，作为一个问题，你知道，这是其中之一，伦敦和纽约之间有20毫秒。所以如果你有一个交易系统，有人说，哦，我们需要让纽约和伦敦在10毫秒内同步，你需要一个诺贝尔奖，因为你不会打破那个限制。这是你没有选择的法律之一。你不能打开一个配置文件说，你知道，我今天只是要改变光速，我认为它应该更快，好吧，让我们用更快的速度重启系统，所以我们发现，这个光速限制是真实的，就我们正在使用的系统而言，它，嗯，我不仅仅是在谈论太空旅行之类的
that because that messes with a whole load of protocols and times at the timeouts you can't have a tcpip connection to the probes on Mars because you'll have timed out with those. But even if I've got something like a geosync satellite, that incurs a round trip of over 100, 150 milliseconds. And so that's really slow. That's noticeably slow for certain classes of system and even for phone calls. So we're always going to build a system and then we're going to hit the limits. And as you say, there's power. We're hitting light speed limits on a number of things that actually prove to be impractical. Yeah, it's not just on communication too. It's also on how many transistors, how densely can I pack transistors? We're starting to reach
因为那会搞乱大量的协议和超时，你不能与火星上的探测器建立TCP/IP连接，因为你会超时。但即使我有一些像地球同步卫星的东西，那也会产生超过100、150毫秒的往返时间。所以这真的很慢。对于某些类别的系统，甚至对于电话通话来说，这都是明显缓慢的。所以我们总是会构建一个系统，然后我们会遇到限制。正如你所说，有电力。我们在许多实际上被证明是不切实际的事情上遇到了光速限制。是的，这不仅仅是在通信上。它也关于有多少晶体管，我可以多密集地封装晶体管？我们开始达到
the point with process technology where there's just not a lot of headroom for us to make smaller transistors we start to to reach a a scale we've started to reach a scale where uh just the physical limitation yeah quantum effects are becoming it says just like no like this yeah you cannot build smaller smaller transistors and that and that's the point's the point and therefore we have to kind of like as it were squeeze the toothpaste in a different direction multi-core etc and I think that
工艺技术的点，那里没有太多的余地让我们制造更小的晶体管，我们开始达到一个规模，我们已经开始达到一个规模，那里，嗯，仅仅是物理限制，是的，量子效应正在变得，它说就像不，就像这个，是的，你不能制造更小更小的晶体管，而这就是重点，这就是重点，因此我们必须，就像，换句话说，向不同的方向挤牙膏，多核等等，我认为
that's the point is every era is going to hit its own limits and regard something as normal and given and so I did so I mentioned Hadoop earlier on the whole idea the map reduce architecture the idea of pushing stuff out into the network just parallelizing the task yeah we break it up into small tasks and do that and i i highlighted um something that um
这就是重点，每个时代都会遇到自己的限制，并认为某些事情是正常的、理所当然的，所以我提到了Hadoop，整个MapReduce架构的想法，把东西推向网络，只是并行化任务，是的，我们把它分解成小任务并做那个，我，我强调了，嗯，某事，对某人，我正在进行一个研讨会，我正在为一家公司进行研讨会。是在哪里？大约2017年。我对某人做了一个观察。我说，好的，所以我们可以把它分解并看看这个。然后我说，看，有人刚刚写了一个脚本来解决这个问题。他们是在内存中完成的。它是基于2014年的一篇博客。他们说他们全部在内存中完成，而历史上他们会使用Hadoop
something to somebody i was running a workshop um i was running a workshop for a company. Where was it? About 2017. And I made an observation to somebody. I said, okay, so we could break this up and look at this. And then I said, look, somebody just wrote a script to solve this problem. And they did it in memory. And it was based on a blog in 2014. and they said they did it all in memory whereas historically they would have used a hadoop
解决方案，他们会说好的，我们要使用一种编译语言，我们要把它散布到网络上，他们说是的，他们只是使用了一个脚本解决方案，因为它全部在内存中，它比所谓的快速最优解决方案快了200多倍。我说，这仅仅归结为光速和网络成本之类的事情。我在研讨会上有个人说，哦，那是因为我们的架构现在更好了。我说，我们知道得更多，回到这个想法。我说，是的，那不是问题。我说，实际上，你10年前不可能做出这个解决方案。它对你不可用，因为你无法寻址那个内存。它根本对你不可用。
solution and they'd have said okay we're going to use a compiled language and we're going to spread it across the network and they said yeah they just use a scripting solution and because it was all in memory it was it was over 200 times faster than the so-called fast optimal solution. And I said, that's simply down to things like the speed of light and the cost of the network. And I had one person in the workshop say, oh, that's because our architectures are better now. And I said, we know more, going back to this idea. And I said, yeah, that's not a problem. I said, actually, you couldn't have done this solution 10 years in the past. It was not available to you because you wouldn't have been able to address that memory. It simply wasn't available to you.
但我说，他说，是的，我们知道我们现在正在做好的架构。我说，我希望你给自己写一封信。在10年后给自己发一封电子邮件，告诉你自己，向未来的自己描述你当前的架构，然后未来的自己会笑，说哦，你以为你已经把一切都搞定了，这就是问题所在，不是说我们得到了一些改进，而是其他事情我们只是在追逐地平线，我们总是会追逐地平线，形状，问题空间在移动，而一代人认为，所以回到很多开发者现在进入这个行业的事实，他们认为有很多
But I said, and he said, yeah, we know that we're doing good architecture now. And I said, I want you to write a letter to yourself. Send yourself an email in 10 years time and tell you describe to your future self what your current architecture is and then your future self will laugh and say oh you thought you had it all worked out that's the problem is that it's not that we get some things are improving but other things we're just chasing the horizon we're always going to be chasing the horizon the the the shape the the problem space moves um and what one generation thinks, and so going back to the fact that a lot of developers are coming into the industry now, they think there's a whole lot
事情是正常的。而在10年后，他们会说，嗯，那不再正常了。或者我假设是正常的东西现在很奇怪或过时了。我刚刚挖出了Douglas Adams的一句精彩名言。他说，我提出了一套描述我们对技术反应的规则，任何在你出生时就在世界上的东西都是正常的、普通的，只是世界运作方式的自然组成部分；任何在你15岁到35岁之间发明的东西都是新的、令人兴奋的和革命性的，你可能可以在其中找到一份职业；任何在你35岁之后发明的东西都是违背自然秩序的，而重点在于，这也是一种社会现象，而且，你知道，导致年长、脾气暴躁的人到处说，哦，在我那个时代
of things that are normal. And in 10 years time, they're going to go, well, that's not normal anymore. Or what I assumed was normal is now weird or antiquated. And I just dug out this wonderful quote from Douglas Adams. And he said, i've come up with a set of rules that describe our reactions to technologies um anything that is in the world when you're born is normal and ordinary and is just a natural part of the way the world works anything that's invented between you uh when you're 15 and 35 is new and exciting and revolutionary and you can probably get a career in it anything invented after you're 35 is against the natural order of things um and and the point there is that this is also this is a social thing and uh you know uh and causes uh uh older grumpy people to go around go oh in my day
你知道，就像，哦，这是不自然的，这是，这是新奇的，而且没有必要，但身处技术领域，我认为这也很有趣。它可能是在更小的时间尺度上。很多人们认为是理所当然的事情，别人必须去争取。但同时，在未来的某个时候，你将不得不承认它要么是家具的一部分，非常理所当然，要么实际上不再相关。不是因为我们进步了，而是因为我们有点向上和向侧面移动了。我们不断地向上和向侧面移动。如果问题空间保持固定，我们总是会向上移动，但我们正在向上和向侧面移动。我们正在遇到新的边界。我们正在遇到新的约束。每次我们解决一个特定的问题，有人就会创造软件
you know just like oh this is unnatural this is on you this is new and fangled and it's not necessary but being inside the technology space i think this is also quite interesting. It's probably on smaller timescales. A lot of things that people regard as a given, somebody else had to fight for. But also, in some time in future, you're going to have to recognize is either part of the furniture, very much given, or is actually no longer relevant. Not because we've progressed, but because we've kind of moved up and sideways. We're constantly moving up and sideways. If the problem space had remained fixed, we'd always be moving up, but we're moving up and sideways. We're hitting new boundaries. We're hitting new constraints. Every time we solve a particular problem, somebody creates software
以不同的方式。我认为，或者我们以不同的方式使用软件。回到这个节目的开头，我们谈到了连接性，我们也被连接的事实改变了我们试图创造的软件，但也改变了我们正在经历的问题。如果我们把自己困在90年代初的那种模式中，那么实际上这一切都会得到解决并且非常稳定，但我们没有，我们不仅仅是向上移动，我们也向侧面移动了。你知道，不一定是为了CPU，但它会来的，每个现代GPU都是一个多芯片模块。我的意思是，它是粘在某种中介层上的独立的微小芯片。所以，每个人都记得，你知道，NUMA系统在GPU之前的HPC时代曾经非常流行。你
in a different way. And I think that that, or we use software in a different way. Going back to the beginning of this, where we talked about connectivity the the fact that we're also connected changes the the very software we're trying to create but it also changes the problems we're experiencing um had we stuck in ourselves in the early 90s kind of mode then actually that would all be solved and very stable but we didn't we didn't just move up we moved sideways as as well. You know, not necessarily for CPUs yet, but it'll come, every modern GPU is a multi-chip module. And by that, I mean, it is separate little chips that are stuck together on some interproser. And so, everybody remembers, you know, NUMA systems used to be all the rage back in the day in HPC before GPUs. You
知道，你会有一个四插槽，你知道，一个八插槽系统，用某种，你知道，疯狂的互连连接。你会在你的进程中拥有所有这些，你知道，你会有这个平坦的内存空间。但实际上，会有一些内存，一些芯片可以比其他芯片访问得更快。而这就是，你知道，迅速成为我们构建每个单独处理器的方式，现在，构建现代芯片的工程大部分投入到了不是芯片本身，而是连接每一个单独模块到中介层上的互连，成为一个单一的东西。而我们今天认为理所当然的这种平坦的内存视图，这是一种非常有用的抽象，
know, you'd have a four socket, you know, an eight socket system connected with some, you know, crazy interconnect. You'd have all of these, you know, you'd have this flat memory space in your process. But in reality, there'd be some memory that some chips could access faster than others. And that that's you know rapidly becoming how we build each individual processor um now and so much of the engineering into building a modern chip goes into the not the chips themselves but also this interconnect that connects each one of those individual modules on the interposer into a single thing. And what we take for granted today of this sort of flat view of memory, which has been an incredibly useful abstraction,
在编程的整个生命周期中，极其强大的抽象。我们有芯片，它崩溃了，仅仅拥有单一内存视图的效用是如此之大，以至于硬件在底层实际上不是那样工作的性能惩罚，并不值得处理它的复杂性。十年后，我们可能生活在一个非常不同的世界里，那些正在进行系统编程的人
incredibly potent abstraction throughout the life of programming. And we've had chips where it's broken down, and just the utility of having a single view of memory has been so great that the performance penalties for that not actually being how the hardware works under the hood has not been worth the complexity of having to deal with it. Ten years from now, we may live in a very different world where people who are doing systems programming
必须更多地考虑不仅仅是分配内存，而是像当我分配这个内存时，这个内存被分配在哪里，你知道，这可能是，你知道，10、15年后，我们编程系统的方式将与今天非常不同。是的，我认为关于系统编程的那一点非常关键，因为那个想法，平坦内存模型的幻觉，一致的内存模型，被烘焙到了我们在C++中发现的东西中。这就是为什么C和C++在历史上在分段架构上经历了如此困难的时期。
have to think a lot more about not just allocating memory, but like when I allocate this memory memory where is this memory being allocated um you know it could be it could be the case that that uh 10 15 years from now the the way we program systems will be very different than they are today yeah i think that that point about systems programming is is is really key because that that idea the the illusion of a flat memory model, a consistent memory model, is baked into something that we find in C++. And that's why C and C++ had such a difficult time on segmented architectures historically.
是的，是的。那里有一种隐含的概念，即你拥有这个。正如你所说，我们正在做的是维持一种幻觉。我们正在维持这种非常强大但方便的抽象。但那种幻觉必须在舞台上支撑起来。它背后发生了很多事情。而且这有代价。但在实践中，我们也在看，我认为，另一个想法，正如你所描述的，每一个芯片都是一个分布式系统。
Yes, yes. There's kind of an implicit notion there that you have this. And exactly as you say, what we're doing is maintaining an illusion. We're maintaining this very powerful but convenient abstraction. But that illusion has to be propped up on stage. There's a whole load of stuff that happens behind it. And there's a cost for that. But in practice, we're also looking at, I think, another idea that, as you described, every single chip is a distributed system.
所以我们通常认为分布式系统，我们认为我们看向世界，那里有分布式系统。实际上，它就在你旁边运行。你有一个分布式系统。而且它对内存是如何组织的有这种非常不同的看法。而那，我认为，如果你不在系统层面，那么幻觉是可以的。没关系。但如果你在系统层面，这就是系统。它用大量的复杂性挑战你。而且拥有语言或范式
So we normally think of distributed systems, we think we look out to the world and there are the distributed systems. Actually, it's running right next to you. You've got a distributed system. And it's got this very different view of how memory is organized. And that, I think, if you're not at the systems level, then the illusion is okay. It's fine. But if you are at the systems level, this is the system. And it challenges you with a lot of complexity. And it's having the languages or the paradigms
实际上会与此对齐，并说，这里有一个简单的思考方式或与此合作的方式。正如你所说，另一个十年可能会在最低层面改变这一点。它绝对不是静止不动的。但在更高层面，人们可能不必担心它。换句话说，上层在这个方面实际上可能更稳定。是的。你知道，这很有趣。我认为我们都是在某种程度上认同自己是系统程序员的人。而且，我认为在某种程度上，这是一个模糊不清的术语。
that will actually align with that and say, here's an easy way to think about it or work with this. And as you say, another decade could shift that at the lowest level. It's definitely not standing still. But at the higher level, people might not have to worry about it. In other words, the upper level is actually potentially more stable in this respect. Yeah. You know, it's interesting. I think we're all people who identify to some degree as systems programmers. And it is, I think, to some degree, a nebulous and vague term.
但对我来说，系统编程是任何形式的编程，在其中你需要，至少在某种程度上，关心平台的底层架构。那可能是操作系统架构，它可能是硬件架构。但它是一种编程类型，你需要考虑系统的整体视图，而不仅仅是应用程序逻辑。你需要考虑我正在为什么编程？是的。这如何被组织？当它运行时，在指令序列方面，在运行时它是如何组织的，管道很重要，缓存行很重要，诸如此类的事实？
But to me, systems programming is any form of programming in which you need, at least to some degree, to care about the underlying architecture of the platform. And that might be operating system architecture, it might be hardware architecture. But it's a type of programming where you need to think about the whole view of the system, not just application logic. You need to think about what is it that I'm programming to? Yeah. How does this get organized? When this is run, how is this organized at runtime in terms of sequence of instructions, the fact that pipelines matter and cache lines matter and stuff like that?
以及它是如何在内存中组织的。然后开始担心那个。我认为从C++的角度来看很有趣的是，C++，虽然我们说它是一种系统语言，它允许我们进行很多这种访问，但它并没有允许我们进行很多这种访问。换句话说，我们目前处于L4缓存，我想，十年后，谁知道呢，L57缓存，谁知道我的处理器会有什么。但C++对此没有意见。它不能谈论那个，因为它不知道那实际上是正在发生的事情，以及我的内存是如何组织的。所以它不能谈论那个。换句话说，它编写的系统，C++是针对它构建的，可以这么说，是C在其中成长的平坦内存模型，进程确实，
And how is this organized in memory? And then to start worrying about that. And I think it's interesting from the C++ perspective is that C++, although we say it's a systems language and it allows us a lot of this access, it doesn't allow us a lot of this access. In other words, we're up at L4 caching at the moment, I think, and 10 years time, who knows, L57 caching, who knows what my process is going to have. But C++ has no opinion on this. It can't talk about that because it doesn't have an idea that that's actually what's going on and how my memory is organized. So it can't speak to that. In other words, it's written the system that C++ is built against, so to speak, is the flat memory model that C grew up under with processes that really,
你所见即所得。你知道，你不必担心所有这些正在发生的魔法，你知道，这种幻觉被维持着。所以C++还没有切入那个。而且很难做到。我们现在谈论那个，就像那是硬件人员担心的事情。
what you saw is what you got. You know, you didn't have to worry about all of this magic happening, you know, this illusion being maintained. And so C++ has yet to cut through that. And it's very hard to do so. We now talk about that as that's the hardware people that worry about that.
我们不再认为它是一个系统程序，但在某种意义上它就是系统。我们经常担心，你知道，我们数据结构的缓存友好性。然而我们不能在语言中谈论缓存。我们必须走出语言去说，哦，缓存很重要，我分析它。但我不能在语言中谈论缓存。我们必须走出语言去说，哦，缓存很重要，我分析它。但我不能在语言内部谈论缓存。
We no longer think of it as a systems program, but in one sense it is the system. And we often worry about, you know, the cache friendliness of our data structures. And yet we can't talk about the cache in the language. We have to step outside the language to say, oh, caching matters, I profile it. But I can't talk about the cache in the language. We have to step outside the language to say, oh, caching matters, I profile it. But I can't talk about the caching inside the language.
它有点像从它那里移除了。所以，你知道，我们是系统编程，但没有足够的对系统的访问，我认为这是一个关于那个主题的有趣故事，也就是我当时在伯克利实验室，天哪，我不记得Cori了。Cori是超级计算机的名字，安装在伯克利实验室。这是一个Xeon Phi系统。它是第二或第三代Xeon Phi。这是第一个作为独立系统的。所以Xeon Phi会启动操作系统并运行操作系统。它不是加速卡。
It's kind of like removed from it. So, you know, we're systems programming, yet without enough access to the system, which I think is an interesting story on that subject, which is I was at Berkeley Lab back when, gosh, I can't remember the Corey. Corey was the name of the supercomputer, was installed at Berkeley Labs. And this was a Xeon Phi system. And it was the second or third generation of Xeon Phi. And this was the first one that was a standalone system. So the Xeon Phi would boot up the OS and run the OS. It wasn't an accelerator card.
它基本上是x86架构，但有更多的核心。我们在Cori中拥有的这个特定芯片，它有这种HBM内存，这种高带宽内存，除了它那种常规内存之外。HBM内存有几种不同的模式。一种模式是显式可编程模式，你可以显式分配这个内存并将其用于快速内存，因为它带宽更高，尽管可能比其他内存延迟稍微低一点。然后还有另一种模式，它只是像另一层缓存一样运作。要切换模式，你需要像重启节点。这就像一个启动时间选项。在HPC领域有一个大奖。它基本上是诺贝尔奖，为了
And it was basically an x86 architecture, but with a lot more cores. And this particular chip that we had in Cori, it had this HBM memory, this high bandwidth memory, in addition to its sort of regular memory. And there were a few different modes for the HBM memory. One mode was an explicitly programmable mode where you could explicitly allocate this memory and use it for fast memory because it was higher bandwidth, although maybe a little bit lower latency than other memory. And then there was another mode where it just acted as like another layer of caching. And to switch between the modes, you need to get to like reboot the nodes. It was like a boot time option. And there's this big prize in the HPC space. It's basically the Nobel Prize for the
它基本上是x86架构，但拥有更多的核心。我们在Cori上使用的这款特定芯片，除了常规内存外，还配备了HBM内存，即高带宽内存。HBM内存有几种不同的模式。一种模式是显式可编程模式，你可以显式地分配这块内存并将其用作高速内存，因为它具有更高的带宽，尽管延迟可能比其他内存稍低一些。另一种模式是它仅作为另一层缓存。要在这些模式之间切换，你需要重启节点。这就像是一个启动时的选项。在高性能计算领域有一个大奖，它基本上就是该领域的诺贝尔奖。
HPC world called the Gordon Bell Prize. And to win a Gordon Bell Prize, you have to do some runs on a big, big supercomputer. And so, when Cori was installed, it was a top 10 supercomputer. And so, right after installation, there were a number of teams, I think it was eight teams, that got exclusive access to this supercomputer for a period of time to do full-scale, full system runs on this 10,000 node cluster to try to get results for a Gordon Bell submission. So, these teams, these were the best of the best. These were the ninjas. They had a ton of developers.
高性能计算领域有一个戈登·贝尔奖。要赢得戈登·贝尔奖，你必须在大型超级计算机上进行一些运行测试。因此，当Cori安装时，它是一台排名前十的超级计算机。在安装完成后，有几个团队，我想是八个团队，获得了一段时间的独家访问权，可以在这个拥有10,000个节点的集群上进行全规模、全系统的运行，以尝试获得戈登·贝尔奖的提交结果。这些团队都是顶尖中的顶尖，他们是真正的技术高手，拥有大量的开发人员。
These were folks who had been spending two years prior to this machine being installed, learning this architecture. Like I can dream in Xeon Phi assembly. You know, I knew this chip very well and everybody else who was working on one of these teams knew this very well. And yet, out of those eight teams, seven of the teams used this chip in the cache mode. Some of those teams were like, it's not worth the effort
这些人在此机器安装前的两年里，一直在学习这种架构。就像我可以梦见Xeon Phi汇编语言一样。你知道，我非常了解这个芯片，而这些团队中的每个人也都非常了解它。然而，在那八个团队中，有七个团队以缓存模式使用了这个芯片。其中一些团队认为，不值得花费精力
of us having to change our code to explicitly use this separate pool of memory. We get a good enough performance boost just using this as cache, just using this implicitly. And only one of the teams tried to use it explicitly, but they ran into too many issues and too many quirks, and they ended up just using it in the cache mode too. And it was such a smart move of Intel. They were like, you know what, We're going to try something new. We're going to have this explicitly programmable mode. But somebody at Intel was like, hey, wait, hang on a second. We got to have a fallback just in case this is really hard for
去修改代码以显式地使用这个独立的内存池。仅仅将其作为缓存隐式使用，我们就能获得足够好的性能提升。只有一个团队尝试显式使用它，但他们遇到了太多的问题和怪癖，最终也只能以缓存模式使用它。英特尔的这一举措非常明智。他们当时想，我们要尝试一些新的东西，我们要有这种可显式编程的模式。但英特尔内部有人说，嘿，等等，我们要有一个后备方案，以防这对用户来说太难了，
people to use and they don't switch to using this thing. We got to have something so that this thing will be usable. And boy, was that a smart decision, because I'm sure almost everybody who used that chip used it in the implicit mode. And it just speaks to how pervasive the flat memory space abstraction is. And hiding caches from users, hiding differences in memory hierarchy from users, so much work in hardware goes into that.
导致他们不去使用它。我们必须确保这个东西是可用的。天哪，那真是一个明智的决定，因为我敢肯定，几乎所有使用该芯片的人都以隐式模式使用了它。这充分说明了扁平内存空间抽象是多么普遍。硬件投入了大量工作来向用户隐藏缓存，向用户隐藏内存层次结构的差异。
And it's worth it because it's very hard to program otherwise. Be sure to check these show notes either in your podcast app or at ADSPthepodcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode as well as a link to a GitHub discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. Low quality, high quantity. That is the tagline of our podcast.
这是值得的，因为否则编程会非常困难。请务必查看您的播客应用程序或ADSPthepodcast.com上的节目说明，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个GitHub讨论链接，您可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。希望您喜欢，祝您有愉快的一天。低质量，高数量。这就是我们播客的口号。
It's not the tagline. Our tagline is chaos with sprinkles of information. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那不是口号。我们的口号是充满信息碎片的混乱。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。